- You'll need to source steel
on this cannon and combine
them into a blade that fulfills
the following parameters.
The length of your blade,
not including the tang,
must be between
12 and 15 inches.
The overall length
of your weapon
must not exceed 22 inches.
You will have three hours
to forge your blades.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Time starts now.
I'm going to go ahead
and guess that we're going
to see some teamwork here.
There is enough actual
steel there for six smiths.
Everybody want some of this?
Yeah, yeah Just take
that to the chop saw.
[imitates chop saw]
So we found out that
the axle for the cannon is
high-carbon spring
steel, which is
a great blade-making material.
On a lot of early
fighting knives,
they would have a
section of brass
on the spine of the knife.
So I decided to add the mild
steel spoke from the wheel
of the cannon and combine these
two different types of steel
to meet the parameters
of the blade build.
Daniel is the only
one of our smiths
that has welded anything
together so far.
I'm using the spoke
because it's the perfect size
for the spine of my knife.
And then I'm going to
rock on with my forging.
There's always a
chance, when you're
heading such a
massive piece of steel
and a small piece of
steel, to forge weld
them together, that
you're going to burn
the small piece of steel.
And I've never forge welded
on this particular type
of spring steel.
So I don't know the exact
parameters for the temperature
limitations for it.
I'm definitely having
second thoughts
about my course of action.
Daniel's got a clear lead.
He's way ahead of
everybody else.
I'm at the point
now to where I can
go ahead and harden the blade.
Daniel has quit
with an hour and 16
minutes left on the clock.
The first thing
I see is a crack
about midway down the blade,
right on the cutting edge.
And I thought, maybe I
can grind this thing out.
So I keep cleaning on
the cutting edge up.
And there's two more cracks
right on the cutting edge.
Wait.
What-- what is happening?
DANIEL: Immediately
sick to my stomach.
What's Daniel doing right now?
What the [bleep] is
happening right now?
Did Daniel abandon his blade?
The last thing on the planet
that I want to do right now
is start all over again.
I don't know why you would
start working on something else
with an hour left
in this competition.
DANIEL: I have no options.
I have to start over.
I've got a long ways to go
and a short time to get there.
I'm going to do everything
I can to catch up.
That just shattered like
glass when I hardened it.
30 minutes!
The second blade isn't nearly
as refined as the first one.
But if I can get
this thing quenched
and get to the grinder for at
least three or four minutes,
I feel like I might
have a chance to make
it through to the second round.
It's not as hard
as I want it to be.
But not every tool steel
is as hard as a file.
So we're moving
on to the grinder.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Bladesmiths, shut
down your machines.
Drop your tools.
This forging round is over.
DANIEL: I definitely royally
screwed up the first blade.
But I am happy that
I didn't give up.
Bladesmiths, in this
first round of competition,
each of you had to source steal
from two different locations
on a cannon.
It's time for the judges to
take a closer look at your work.
All right, Daniel,
please present
your blade to the judges.
MAN 1: This was really
smart, fast work.
I would love to see
that fitted up better.
But you hammered this
out and got this done
in basically half the time.
And you've got just
enough of a tang
here for a blade this size.
So seeing how you're going
to connect the handle,
work it into this blade,
and work it into that guard
is going to be interesting.
Good job.
Thank you very much, sir.
Jesse, you're up next.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
MAN 2: Well, Jesse, you started
with a huge piece of steel.
I think it really hindered
you in your ability
to get things moving.
The handle is kind of
big in all dimensions.
I like that you designed a
chopper, but it is quite rough.
I mean, it's still rectangular.
Despite all of it, you
turned something in
and it meets the parameter.
- Thank you.
WIL: Collin, you're up.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
That kind of drop
to the handle--
I mean, it'll be
interesting, moving forward,
to see how you're going to
deal with this whole section
and incorporate
it into a handle.
Bladesmiths, the judges have
completed their deliberation
and they've made
a final decision.
The bladesmith
leaving the forge--
Jesse, your blade
did not make the cut.
Doug Marcaida's going
to tell you why.
Jesse, I hope you take from
this experience to continue on,
because the world
awaits your work.
But at the end of the day, your
blade was the least finished.
And that's the reason
we're sending you home.
Jesse, please
surrender your blade.